[Music]
amy is with us in dallas hi amy how are
you
i'm doing great mr ramsey and uh rachel
i have to say i love that you're on
because i too like to spend a portion of
my entertainment budget at the craft
stables
[Music]
this is not the way to start out the
call amy
dave is dying i mean you just you
started out in the hole okay and now you
gotta dig out amy could have said
conspiracy theories craps or love is
blind and i would have been like this is
my girlfriend
i am on baby step seven i am a i'm 33
years old um i think i have a pretty
good net worth of around 2 million
i don't i so i hope i'm hoping i'm
getting better on your graces in spite
in spite of your problem with the craps
okay
yeah
um but i'm kind of just um so i i'm an
engineer my husband's an engineer we're
very process oriented people
we're just kind of struggling like we we
just read the legacy journey
and like you know like what our next
like goal should be we really don't want
to be landlords no offense
but
um
so and now right now we're just
you know we have pretty substantial
raises this year so we're gonna make 30
000 more than we made last year
and it's just it's just
like it feels like there's just more
money coming in and we're like you know
i guess we're just saving more yeah well
you're doing great you've done such an
amazing job congratulations when you are
the everyday millionaire of
uh our babysitter's millionaire uh both
yeah sure
yeah two engineers i mean everything
you're like the classic
except the fact that you're 33 yeah way
to go amazing
yeah so your biggest problem is
it's just um
you're overwhelmed with prosperity in a
sense
right yes and and obviously we're we're
christians and and we give and i even
put my budget random giving above the
you know 10 like and so
it's just and now i just feel like it
was just
like our last goal was paying off our
house right and then there was like
making sure our kids college fund is set
and we don't have to touch it forever
and
it's like now what
okay yeah i mean it's i mean at this
point i mean you really we always say
the three things you can do with money
you can give it
you can save and invest it and you can
spend it and so you need to be doing all
three of those so i love that you upped
your giving uh because that's a big part
of this right that you live like no one
else so later you live and give like no
one else right so
uh having that flow out is gonna be it's
gonna be amazing i mean like you're
gonna run into things and god's gonna
put things in your path
that you didn't even realize was there
and it's gonna come up and you're going
to be able to write a check or you're
going to help someone in a significant
way which is just so fun and so you're
going to get to experience that on a new
level uh and then yeah i think
continuing to invest so if real estate's
not something that you're like oh you
feel you know great about or you guys
want to do
um obviously just even opening up a
mutual fund talking to a smartmaster pro
and continuing to to put money in just
investing
uh is something that you could look at
but if you guys i don't know if you have
an interest of like
i don't know you want to
i never know what you think about this
stuff but i don't know i don't know okay
that's the spin category so i want you
to up your lifestyle for sure yes and
you all enjoy something that's our
problem okay let me look now let me tell
you let me tell you what's happening
because it happened it's happened to me
years ago
um and i watch it happen when i'm
working with people hit
these uh the baby steps millionaire's
goals and they get where you are okay
what happens is there's two things one
is you have this hard concrete goal
and it was the end of the race and you
broke through the tape
and you're like okay i need to i need a
goal because this feels like i'm just
kind of floating out here that's thing
one that happens this sense of
disconnect because you were so connected
to and driven towards a goal now there's
nothing and it's just floating
and that's very disconcerting the second
thing that happens is and this is more
pronounced than than that one that one
you do get over fairly quickly just by
getting another goal but the second
thing that happens is when you didn't
when you haven't been around this many
zeros
you emotionally it takes a little while
to get used to it
i mean i'll give you an example around
here i mean the ramsey organization is
several hundred million dollars a year
in revenue and so we spend more on
copier paper
than i used to spend than i used to make
in a year you know
we spend more on coffee than some people
make in a year you know i mean it's just
nuts just because of the scale right and
it's hard to get used to
even today and i've been doing it for 30
years you know so but today i look down
at our profit and loss statement and i
see the bill for coffee and i'm like
sheesh
you know and it's an emotional
experience i'm a kid from antioch
tennessee we spent that on coffee you
know and is this kind of weird it's it's
an emotional thing so it takes a little
while for your emotions to catch up with
your math
for you to get used to
buying something
that cost
30 000 bucks
and you don't even feel it like most
people buying a candy bar
okay because that's the position you're
moving into you're going to be able to
go and buy an item
or a thingy of some kind a trip
whatever for your just to enjoy just to
consume
that is a large amount of money compared
to the way you grew up compared to what
you've always been up to this date
but it's a small amount of money
relative mathematically to where you are
and so you still have this like oh my
gosh you know
and so i was with a guy i'll give you an
extreme example of that okay i was with
a guy not long ago who made 15 million
dollars last year
he's he's killing it okay
and
actually would know his name if i said
it so i'm not going to say it but the uh
but he drove up to my house in a car
that cost 300 grand
and we were having this exact discussion
because the car is freaking killer
believable car you know and we're
standing there looking at this and he
goes man i grew up in dot dot dot
and he goes i can't even
i can't get my head around the fact that
i just bought this car and i just drove
it up here in your house he goes i feel
like kind of dirty like i did something
wrong well let's do the percentages 300
grand as a percentage of 15 million
okay it's like buying a thirty thousand
dollar car if you made a million and a
half a three thousand dollar car if you
made a hundred and fifty thousand
it's the same ratios
right so did you do something wrong no i
didn't you know he's not out of line
it's a small but people say stuff like
no one needs a car like that well for
him it's like buying a biscuit
you know it doesn't show up it doesn't
move the needle and so that's where it
is with you your emotions are having
that same kind of a thing when you
invest a large sum give a large sum i
mean the first time i gave ten thousand
dollars to something my mind was blown
i was like whoa
you know
and and because it was the most i had
ever done and it was not an emotional
amount i was used to
and so that's what you're experiencing
so expect to feel disconnected until you
have a good goal and expect for it to be
emotionally disconcerting for a little
while as you lay out and say we're going
to spend x on enjoyment we're going to
spend y on investing and we're going to
spend
z on giving and you're going to increase
all of those and they're going to be
uncomfortable yes so amy i would say
like my husband and i when we we all we
always kind of have a goal we have a
goal within a 12 24 month period that we
can hit
uh whether it's a new car or we want to
do you know a certain trip or
i don't know so put it in a pool like i
don't know what it is we a house was a
big one for us so in 2019 is when we
moved in but that was a goal we had for
years to do that so so find the thing
you and your husband
i'm assuming i'm i'm going to assume
you're married i think you said that but
they should have two engineers that's
right that's right um
that you guys are excited about like
have that goal that you're yes putting
money in a mutual fund all that but that
goal it's there's still something
energizing that you have to be able to
shoot for so find something that you and
your husband agree like that's fine what
maybe it's building your dream home like
i don't care what it is but there's
something out there that you look at and
you guys are continuing to work and be
intentional and then on the lifestyle
side i would i would force yourself
force yourself to spend
a certain amount of money every month
just to get used to it because you can
and you should be able to enjoy it too
that would be very nice and on the
generosity above the tides the
generosity above the tithes should go up
all of these are going to be a little
uncomfortable because it's your first
time to play with numbers this size it's
emotionally like looking at the coffee
line and going what